[Music]
i'm an american writer
the author of the best seller lefleux
phantom on france ghost fleet united
states which explored
the war that the u.s may have with china
in the 2020s more recently uh as of
today i have a new book called control
which is going to be coming it's out in
france about the coming collision with
artificial intelligence and robotics i'm
obsessed with trying to figure out
what's next what are the problems that
society is rushing towards that it may
be missing these big ideas these big
conflicts are something that just are
are very much what i wake up every day
trying to trying to think more about and
of course use fiction to understand
i am lucky enough to work with an
american writer named peter singer his
pen name is pw singer and we've had a
partnership that is at this point about
eight years old and in my old life i
used to be a journalist in washington dc
at the washington excuse me at the wall
street journal
and he was a source of mine when i was
writing about private military companies
defense matters drones particular areas
of expertise of his
and we formed a partnership out of that
friendship once i quit journalism and i
left it behind over a dozen years ago
and that led us to working first on
ghost fleet and now our latest book
[Music]
it's a super question and in 2022 is
arguably one of the most important ways
to unlock real insight into the future
especially the future of conflict
what writers and particularly writers
who are willing to do the research and
write fact-based future fiction can do
is better understand
everything from
aspects of future conflict like human
machine teaming whether you can trust a
robot to a really big idea whether china
is a nation that's capable of defeating
the united states
one of the best things that writers can
do in thinking about the future is talk
about the things that nobody wants to
talk about
that the status quo is often reinforced
by everything from think tanks to
government research reports and those
have their place but we're at a moment
where we have to be more creative we
have to think the unthinkable and find
ways to integrate that into everything
from defense planning to strategy to
simply communicating with the public and
helping them understand what's happening
in the world because that's often not
done there's too much people talking to
themselves and the novels that i've been
writing with peter singer the other work
that i do is very much about trying to
address that
she
is
i think that is a question of incentives
and also
the medium itself you know there's the
idea that the medium is the message that
marshall think mcclellan coat from a
long time ago
if all you're allowed to do is create
powerpoint briefs
in a basement office in the pentagon
it's very difficult to introduce a very
disruptive idea that your boss may hate
that their boss may find unacceptable
and so the question then becomes if
you're working in an official
organization whether it's in the
intelligence community or in a military
service
one of their branches
what is the best way to break outside of
that silo
and there is nothing better than story
to do this humans are literally wired
like machines
to understand story to share story
whether it's written or spoken it
doesn't matter but fundamentally this is
a very human endeavor
and the reason why i think it's
important as well to to think about this
approach in an official way
is that we have so much technological
change right now
whether it's the rise of new forms of
computing like quantum computing whether
it's the rise of more sophisticated and
autonomous drones
information and cognitive warfare
whatever the subject
what we often forget and i see people
missing in those conversations
at the official level
is that we are all going to live in that
future
and this is a little bit like in the
design community when you're trying to
understand
from a user experience
what is the actual problem that somebody
faces
and that's very much how a good writer
thinks i believe too when they're taking
this approach
[Music]
questions
it's really all of those elements
together maybe not the last one as much
people telling us you know more or less
what to to write but the idea that
when i think about what's a what's a big
issue worth writing a book about because
a book takes years and you're really
committing a lot of energy emotional
intellectual professional there's risk
and that it may fail nobody may read it
in fact with lefleut phantom it might
have been easier for us to have written
a non-fiction book that would have been
the logical the la the rational or
linear approach
but the stakes for this question that we
had come upon which was
was the u.s underestimating china's
military rise and we definitively
concluded yes
more so that it was very unpopular in
2013 2014
to talk about in public china is a
threat
from an analytical perspective but not
it was not a broadly or widely accepted
conversation in washington dc at least
this is true in the public sense there
was a u.s naval officer who was fired at
the time for saying so at a public
professional conference in 2000 i
believe 14.
and even though we had a pivot to asia
even though we had this idea that
america had to reorient from central and
middle east to the asia pacific that's a
lot harder to do than it is to declare a
policy but going back to the origin of
the idea
when there is a large consensus around a
concept in this case that china
was a nation that the u.s could overcome
the nation that china didn't master
certain technologies you wouldn't be
able to really get a lead in ai or sixth
generation jet stealth whatever
when there's a large consensus like that
my immediate response is what are people
missing like what is the blind spot why
does everybody want to believe that so
when everybody is looking this way my
instinct is often what's over there
right
another way to think about it is to
simply invert the assumptions that
people hold the dearest
another example that we explored in the
flood phantom in ghost fleet was this
notion of technological supremacy
and how important that the u.s at the
time assumed that would be in a 21st
century a world war global conflict
and so we started to unpack and look at
things from a chinese perspective it's a
little bit this red team in a war game
sense point of view
where if you only play your own side if
you only think about things as you've
been taught to and trained to and are
rewarded to you're often going to miss
potentially the way an adversary is
going to go about exploiting those
assumptions
any adversary worth their
salt as we say in english whether it's
the chinese pla whether it's russian
intelligence is going to look at the
opportunities
and find exactly how
they can take those strengths that their
adversary has and turn them into a
weakness so that was part of the process
another aspect in that is this is a
novel a thriller techno thriller
but it has end notes it has
hundreds of end notes because we wanted
to be transparent with our readers about
what we were seeing
that the evidence is all there in the
open but you have to kind of put it
together
and we used a creative vehicle to do
this a novel but those endnotes and
those in the story could have very well
been the same endnotes for a non-fiction
book
i've had some really interesting
experiences i was at fort benning in
georgia doing a talk there we have a an
american center where infantry officers
are trained there's an airborne school
and i was getting a tour of the airborne
jump facilities and the the master
sergeant there
is walking me through the the the field
and he says to me he said you know the
book checks out and i was like okay like
you liked it he's like no i mean i
looked up every single footnote
i checked them all out they're valid
the reason why i tell that story is that
those are about establishing credibility
with a military reader i'm a civilian
right i'm a writer i'm not somebody who
has those experiences but i have an
interest in those same issues and being
able as well to use those footnotes as a
manner of establishing a bona fides of
sorts which is that we've done the hard
work the homework
and establish those facts then then we
put them in the book so the reader can
do their own research and maybe come to
different conclusions
this is an important facet too i think
when you're writing about the future
some people
feel they have to be right all the time
when it comes to thinking about the
future they want to be the person who
predicts the future and i don't know
that that's always possible
but the act of doing so the process
is really really valuable because you're
able then even if you don't get a
precise prediction
you've at least hopefully gotten outside
of your assumptions in your comfort zone
and thought about some of the riskier or
more controversial ideas that may in
fact may in fact reflect a reality of
the future
[Music]
um
i'm certain that
certain parts of the us military
at the time in the late in before 2015
2014 2013 were very focused on exactly
those kinds of sea lions of
communication
those you know resource access choke
points right however
one of the biggest challenges in
thinking about the kinds of conflicts
that were think that we're discussing is
that you may have a certain part of the
force
even intellectually that understands the
problem
but if our political leaders aren't
taking it seriously if the mandate isn't
given to accept and acknowledge a threat
because it's destabilizing to commercial
relationships or other things diplomacy
then it's a very precarious position to
be at a national level strategically
because there's a
disconnect between the two from a war
fighting perspective a war plans
perspective for sure
there are quite sophisticated and
comprehensive plans for all kinds of
contingencies of course
but the difference is being able to act
on them at a national level well before
they're needed and that's part of what i
think we're trying to do with these
kinds of projects is to use them to
create an awareness which is to say
you may think an inevitability you're
trying to avoid is
10 years away maybe 12 13
but you have to pretend
or prepare i should say
that it's much much more pressing that
it's coming out as potentially far
sooner because we don't control how fast
our adversaries advance whether it's
their strategic ambitions their vision
of their role in the world russia is a
good example of this right now with
ukraine
xi jinping in china is a very good
example as well his transformation in
the last four years
to articulating a vision that's much
more mao like right both domestically
and externally i think i think that
reconciliation is hard to do and so we
have to think about new ways to do it
[Music]
the conflict
that's a very big question uh certain
time
certainly um
in you know having uh
on 911 i was in chicago and in in the
working in the board of trade building
as a journalist for at the time cbs
marketwatch
and
i remember looking up at the television
that we had on the american cable news
network called cnbc it's financial news
and
one of our jobs was to have that on all
the time and so you're kind of always
watching it but not really paying
attention and in a moment
you saw
a flash of light that they cut to
because they'd been focusing on
twin towers after the first
plane hit it but it was the second that
was really the moment where you realized
that everything changed because there
was a very faint flash of white
when that aircraft hit the second tower
and then as the image pulled back
the subsequent different shots you
understood better what was happening and
every american has a moment
that they can reflect on and what
followed in the weeks after that sense
of numbness and shock
i think the military response into
afghanistan was a natural and correct
reflection of that right of trying to
pursue the people who perpetuated the
threat
when you look forward to the invasion of
iraq
and the politics
the positioning of that one of the
things that was really troubling at the
time
was that
different communities in washington had
different reasons and answers for why we
needed to go to war
there was the threat of weapons of mass
destruction there was the neocon
position of bringing liberty or
democracy
and as an analyst as a journalist that
felt very troubling that there was so
much inconsistency not to say that any
one of them
didn't make sense to the people making
those arguments but to me that was
troubling and it's something i
occasionally will think about because
we're going to have to ask ourselves
as we do now with ukraine and russia as
we're going to have to do with china and
taiwan potentially or some other part of
the indo-pacific asia-pacific
do we have confidence in political
leaders who are making the case to take
a nation to war
is there a coherent message that's not
just for in my country's case our
population but our allies too
so i see the two is different in a sense
and having that ability to understand in
my case
the troubling signs when analyzing what
happened and having of course withdrawn
from iraq and most recently afghanistan
and seeing the country fall it's an
incredible tragedy and one that should
have been anticipated and it has been
incredibly painful for my friends who
are uniform who spent much of their
careers
anticipated
anticipation
oh uh in speaking about afghanistan and
understanding
the fall of the country
to the taliban the rapidity and speed
with which that happened
caught many people off guard and it
shouldn't have um
out on iraq on the political positioning
up front
i think in 2022 it's been
moved past it's not something that comes
up in popular conversation it may again
again like i was i was trying to
articulate the idea that when the state
is asked to go to war
and we are always as americans going to
have to answer for
what powell said right to go to the u.n
like that
and that is something that is going to
be just as vital when we think about
the conflicts to come in the future too
because once you break trust like that
it's very very difficult to build it
back domestically and i would say in
this day and age it gets harder and
harder to do so because there is so much
so little i should say trust already in
larger governments bigger systems
organizations
and that's something that in the last
two decades literally
has has
has intensified and is only going to get
more difficult
and can any nation
ask an appeal to its people to support
an operation like that again a western
nation invading another country
that's a very very big question
[Music]
no no i don't i don't think that if i
understand correctly
the
international criminal court
uh no but i i don't think that it would
it would be
sensible to to try to try to do that to
america's leaders in that era at the
governmental level
no
the
[Music]
so reckoning with our past to understand
our future if i understand correctly
so
with with an organization like wikileaks
fundamentally changed the conversation
in the u.s
by offering primary source evidence
right of abu ghraib of other instances
like that civilian casualties
and for all the efforts that that
we have made since in trying to move
past that that fundamentally has changed
how other countries perceive us
and from an accountability perspective
in from a foresight and futures
perspective
knowing that that is a part of conflict
and that actually happened right that's
not from someone's imagination and that
the public has experienced that through
wikileaks right through the media
coverage
through the the um
the
they have the but but to actually have
it's not abstract to them in the way
that they have experienced it you can
read a story but you can actually now
see a proper the
original report
you can watch a video of a gunship you
know hitting the wrong target
that is a new paradigm that is going to
continue and so in thinking about that
and the ability of leaders to lie
is crucial in being honest about
thinking about what's coming in the
future it's certainly an aspect i think
that you have to be able to consider
that human aspect the nature of power
the nature of how people will wield it
and how warfare has always a political
element that many times has this
domestic side to it
the american general from the 90s former
presidential candidate
i don't have a lot of experience reading
or i've never met wesley clark so it'd
be hard for me to say
generationally kind of where to fit
given his you know
supreme allied commander europe correct
but i don't i don't have a strong
opinion having not spent much time
never met him or worked with him or
anything like that
you know having spent so much of my
career as a journalist i spent a lot of
time learning how to you know talk to
people and and in many cases getting
people to talk to me who didn't want to
to be to build trust and and that
actually served me really well as a
writer of fiction
because
many of the people when i when i quit my
job at the wall street journal i left it
to go on this very winding path of using
fiction and
and and i had this really interesting
experience i thought because that
working at the wall street journal in
the us is a very prestigious
job in american journalism
and i thought no in washington dc is a
place
where your title and where you work
matters when you meet someone in
washington dc
it's quite funny the first thing people
say where do you work right so really it
really matters
so i walked away from
this job where when i told them where i
worked everyone's like wow right
um
and i thought i would be essentially a
nobody no one would ever talk to me
again right and i had a lot of really
great sources who i trusted who brought
me things sometimes sometimes i had to
hunt them down
when they didn't want to talk to me and
you have a back and forth
when i quit the journal though
i had the most interesting thing happen
is that people were happy they said this
is great now we can finally talk
they weren't worried about being quoted
in the newspaper in the same way
and that was an interesting development
because
when you over time over a couple years i
worked at the journal just under three
years
you know you during because of the
intensity of the job do get to know
people pretty well because you're
talking to them often in very stressful
situations when you need something
immediately and they don't want to give
it to you or you're getting context
having a more you know casual
conversation but fundamentally about
having been
i think trustworthy in that sense
meaning that when you're reporting and
covering whether it's a company a
department or agency
even breaking news
being the person that they want to talk
to because they know you'll get it right
when people who are careless with facts
or
are inconsiderate with their sources
it's hard to develop a trusting
relationship even if there's a bit of
antagonism to it
you want to be the person that when bad
news happens people tell you
so that's like my old journalism life
now when working on these books like
ghost fleet which even though it has
these really comprehensive footnotes
right the endnotes at the end the detail
are primary source research
stories articles whatever
we're always looking
to get the human element right because a
good novel is about people fundamentally
and it's important almost that like
an anthropological level
just to know
how to convey what someone's reality is
like i'm constantly trying to understand
what it's like to literally sit in
someone's shoes or to stand in someone's
shoes
and i approach that with a lot of
humility
and i think
that is really really important to never
ever try to be in a position where
you're telling someone hey i'm the
smartest person in the room i know more
than you especially when you're writing
about the future and things that haven't
happened yet
directly can
i mean
it's a big country there's a lot of
different kind of people
no but i mean really to do this work
well right to go into rooms where i'm
the least expert person
whether it's an area you know in the
security realm or working with people
who have far more experience than me
um
you know understanding what i can bring
to that conversation and being being
clear with myself about that
and understanding what what they have to
offer to is really important
what's interesting in the idea that
you'd mentioned about whether we're kind
of chasing people down for for
information or or stuff
there's certainly times when we want to
um you know in us in ghost fleet trying
to describe what it's like to fly an
f-35 fighter if you're being pursued by
a chinese missile
i'm not a pilot i've never sat in an
f-35 you know that could fly
um so we reached into our community
and uh
yeah exactly
any any jet
there are no more stealth jets whether
it's rain whether it's paint coming off
them or you know wideband radar um
so we reached into some of our contacts
and relationships about people who flew
these kind of jets
and could get a little bit of
perspective from that and you know we're
careful about things like
classifications and clearances to and
you know people won't tell us things
they're not supposed to obviously but
it's really important because we want to
describe uh
what it might actually feel like to be
pursued by a chinese missile that's
homing in
on a hacked piece of hardware on your
own jet
what it would be like to no longer trust
your machine right you've spent your
entire career working to get in the
behind the stick on and suddenly in an
instant you realize it's the biggest
vulnerability of all and you're gonna
die
uh that's a really hard thing to write
as a lay person right as an outsider
so so we do that um
i think that's that's that's a really
critical part of why the work we do can
connect
now having written
leflot phantom
having written control which came out in
the us in 2020
people come more and more to us to have
conversations about what's coming to ask
questions about the future operating
environment
and so those conversations get easier
and easier each year
but another way of thinking about like
these projects is that everyone is in a
sense an experiment when we wrote ghost
la flat fenton we had no idea whether
anyone was going to read it whether it
would be laughed at
for writing a novel for emulating old
tom clancy from 1986
uh
red storm rising uh which in on in
france has a different title but
um
but we felt that it was worth the risk
similarly with control we've written a
book that's not about
another war with china right it's not
about
that at all it's said in washington d.c
it's a counter-terrorism story
[Music]
i'm just making the point that every
project
is an experiment
um
um i have a lot of concerns about the
next two years uh the
particularly in light of what's
happening in ukraine
one of the things that worries me goes
goes to this idea of like national
narrative that from a if you're vladimir
putin in thinking about the russian
story
and the remaining years he has in his
life
and the power he's amassed the money
he's he's he's banked the people who
guard his money for him he's the
wealthiest man in the world most likely
and he has a lot to lose personally but
yet has nothing to lose at the same time
nationally
one of my worries is that one of the
grand experiments that he was running
with the invasion of ukraine where he
attempted and wanted to have a surgical
strike an information campaign which
completely failed
is that that objective was very much
about fracturing europe politically
the nato alliance specifically
and he still has others
for me yeah he didn't yeah yeah this is
my analysis right this is how i make
sense of it
and there are people who are more expert
on russia than me to be clear this is
again something i need to be clear about
but but i'm just going to follow my gut
instincts and
he has still a few levers left though to
try to achieve those goals
his information warfare campaigns aren't
working right which one putin
but the the
the attempt to uh fracture the nato
alliance the coherence right
but what if he were to take
a step that involved the military strike
against the nato nation maybe an
airfield in poland where javelin
missiles are transitioning maybe it is
against finland
a neighboring nation which is recently
planning on joining nato to force the
article 5 discussion within nato as a
way
to actually make the alliance decide
what it's really about
and
i've been one of my biggest surprises
i'm sometimes asked what surprised you
about this conflict
and one of the things that has surprised
me has been so far the unity in europe
and also across the atlantic with the us
also with the uk
on supplying arms on supplying resources
right
there was not a fracturing of that of
that relationship
but we're still early in this game
we haven't gone through a full winter
yet
without russian energy we still don't
know what's coming in the fall
strategically and so the next two years
to me seem really really important from
a next six months perspective because
meanwhile xi xinping
even though he may have an objective of
taking taiwan whatever that might look
like by 2027 or whatever the whatever
the target might actually be
is certainly watching and learning and
listening and seeing how committed
america particularly
is going to be to its european defense
obligations even while at the same time
is of course
creating new ones in the pacific like
august
for example with uk and australia
[Music]
this is where what peter and i do right
we're constantly going against each
other
so to sit on the other side of the table
from what i just said
one of the ways i might unpack that
would be
if putin himself in fact
no no no
perspective
america
only
yeah i mean i i think we're in uncharted
territory in the terms of this concept
of economic warfare and for american
interests
our policy is going to have to suddenly
come to grips with the fact that we just
disconnected the west russia
and one of the long-term effects on our
you know trade relationship with europe
we just don't know yet but america's
overall interests i think are
increasingly focused
in a meaningful way actually on the asia
pacific in terms of keeping china within
its second island chain
keeping our allies especially australia
who we're realizing i think year by year
is even more important for us in terms
of power projection and when you look at
like the overall
chinese ambition for
uh belton road one belt one road
understanding that that is in the kind
of uh american naval thinking tradition
mayhem like you're trying to control the
sea lines of communication globally
you're trying to control the information
networks globally
we have to figure out ways to counter
that and the question is i think really
important and and
and focused on this notion of whether
that countering is
economic and political or whether it is
hard power right is it more nested in
defense
and so that that is that is one of the
abiding questions of how do you counter
china because we're going to be living
in a world where china's economy
is larger than any other nation in the
world whether military spending
may
essentially become greater than ours by
the end of this decade
where their military is more
professional now that is political
implications inside china too which is
another conversation but
that is one of the abiding american
questions it's very hard to talk about
which is how do you live in a world what
kind of nation can america be when china
is going to be
more more powerful economically which
has never happened before for us and
potentially more more capable and
powerful militarily
what fascinates me about this question
of legacy and history in china and and
their anger over the opium wars is still
very real um but elf the communist party
itself is still quite young right you
know the communist party i think was
formed in 1928 but the nation itself was
1949 you know modern china um
one of the things i've wondered is how
long can the chinese communist party
survive the inherent contradictions in
that society every year especially as
their technology sector grows as their
military gets more professional
is going to force some really really
difficult moments for them i mean that's
why in flat phantom we posited the
chinese communist party was gone
you know that it just can't it doesn't
make any sense to run that country
anymore
but there it is suborning the pla
managing an economy that doesn't respond
to central planning
it's a fascinating conundrum they have
and society
[Music]
so one of the
the primary interests that this
rise of china presents is how can you
keep the global economy and political
and cultural networks still aligned
around a western and open system right i
that feels to me like the most important
thing the us needs to be able to do
to push back against that aspect of
china's rise because we can't we can't
afford to out-compete them economically
our our country is too small
which is a strange thing to say as an
american because our country is you know
the most you know economically
triumphant in the world
no not intellectually i would say
economically um as a center of
innovation and this is
part of this vision right if america
yeah if america loses its ability to be
the place and this sounds very cliche
where the smartest people in the world
want to come and make money and be free
then we're going to be in a very bad
place if we have a society that's too
extreme too violent to dysfunctional
that's all going to erode that and it
may be slow it may be slow
actually
it's we're not no we're not there yet
thankfully yeah
yep
i think every year it's going to get
harder and harder if our political
system continues to be dysfunctional i
think we can continue
especially as we are so interlinked
again economically to a point
but the offer from a chinese perspective
we have to it's a competitive situation
that we're in
especially with europe
i think this is one of the abiding
questions for china can can china steal
europe away from
the western orientation towards across
the atlantic
that's a really profound strategic
concept to consider because it is of
course not a question of as i said
earlier hard power but of economic
enticement and inducement of opportunity
and currently because of
the chinese political system it's
repressive it's not a place where we're
it's very difficult to do business uh
that's hard
but in the long term 21st century
hundred year strategy
that the uf the us and china are looking
at the end of the 22nd 21st century in
thinking about which nation is going to
be thriving
then
that question has to be answered it's
almost some people have called it like
the opera
the the ability to become almost in our
case maintain the operating system of
the world as some people have described
it or if the chinese are able to rewire
that because that affects everything
from the primacy of the dollar
to the ability to capture economic value
and innovation to control trade routes
the physical movement of objects we may
have revolutions in
3d printing that change the way goods
are made in manufactures that allow a
national you know
awakening again of manufacturing we may
become less dependent on oil in the
middle east because of
solar energy or maybe fusion
but fundamentally the trade routes of
the world will still be just as vital
and i sound a little bit old school
saying that but i as much as i think
about the future you have to always
remember the past
it's again one of those really i think
foundational ways
to consider what's coming especially on
a longer term you know much of the much
of the work i do is focused on the next
10 to 20 years kind of at the outset of
20. but when you really think longer
term
to that 2050 2060 i mean you have to
talk about space of course too
at least near space but especially just
looking at the larger patterns of human
movement you know in the last 2 300
years as we began to enter the age of
maritime commerce and of course now we
have aviation
that's going to remain and remain just
as important as it ever has been even if
it changes forms slightly
revenues
the first i would say
goes back to this idea of being the
physical place
even though we're going to enter a more
virtualized world where people want to
come and thrive
the second would be creating a secure
from a defense perspective
global commons that means cyber it means
increasingly space and of course the sea
that we can affect let other people be
as they say in economics free riders
on our strength right that you can send
ships across an ocean and not worry
about them making it to the other side
that's a role that china has not wanted
to play it's very expensive and we can
barely afford doing it with our own navy
and and maybe with the third i would say
the aesthetic the the maintenance and
and curation
of relationships that served us well in
the last century and i think about the
us european relationship our allies
there's another way of thinking about
this third point which is can you make
new friends
right
because we're gonna have
turmoil and turbulence in given
countries
some countries may peel out of our orbit
but the idea though is that if america
is to be not only a place people want to
come like the first point but
simultaneously as we look out we have to
remain engaged in the world at that
level
and being able to keep people coming on
to our side and that's a question of of
course trust you know to your earlier
points about iraq it's a question of
opportunity the people
at a leader level but also at a street
level and increasingly and this is kind
of my futurist brain
the way that a country like america can
appeal to people is as much about an
idea and of course ideas have
inconsistencies and contradictions i
know that
but the notion of an idea of a story is
still really really important
international relations and maybe even
more so as we get more and more
virtualized that the idea is
in a sense the thing
i was going to make a joke about
croissant cafe
no um
i would say the french fries
french fries in france are actually
with freedom fries
french fries yeah um look i mean from a
european perspective
if america is a young country the
european union itself is still a very
young experiment as well
you know if you consider the idea
of avoiding
when i lived in france in the in the mid
90s
during the kind of emergence of the
european union it was very interesting
to listen to french people talk about
the rise of the eu as being a way to
think about
what to do with germany in the 21st
century
and so i think a peaceful europe where
the european union is viable and allows
an economic
integration and i'm not someone who
completely believes that economic
integration is of course something that
can keep warfare from happening our two
world wars in the 20 and 20th century
prove that's not the case
but i think it does give you a better
shot of avoiding conflict of creating
out of not shared values at least shared
interests
so i would say the european experiment
continuing is important
being i haven't talked about the idea of
global warming and kind of the aspects
of the reimagining of the energy economy
europe may have a better lead at doing
that
than the us
and that has strategic advantage
potentially
the third i would say
the third i would say is
dealing with the societal
transformations and
and this is
not me specifically trying to mention
the book but rather that we are in an
era where
populations are going to have fewer and
fewer economic opportunities
and in europe there is a very high
standard in the social contract much
higher than in america
what people expect in terms of health
care in terms of benefits whether we
have basic income
that is going to be a very very
difficult problem
especially for europe's wealthiest
nations
because people are very invested in
what's happening and it's going to be
economically increasingly difficult to
do
to fulfill those obligations
that has implications for everything
from
defense spending
because if you're looking at budgeting
as a zero-sum game meaning money from
one account is going to go to the other
right
do we pay for basic income or do we pay
for
six generation squadrons of fighters
that is a very difficult thing to
reconcile and has huge implications uh
and it fascinates me as a question some
of the the short fiction that i've
worked on has been trying to to
understand that even from a french a
french perspective
uh what are the what are the choices you
know could france for example in this
scenario hold on to its army
uh of human forces in an era in the
2040s where many other european nations
have automated their forces and keep
them
as a crisis
element
it's robot sized you put it in a cave or
in a bunker and you only use it when you
need it
but there's cultural there's political
reasons to do that and it's a really
from a futures perspective like really
really interesting and so it ties into
that third
notion about managing this this this
problem
the thing that i think about with china
most often is if you're in xi xin ping's
perspective
or you're a senior communist party
official is how do you keep the country
from falling apart
how do you keep
it a coherent
political system
that is so hard to do there the the
heterogeny in the economy in
in culture in that society given its
scale
is
is unprecedented in human history
especially as it collides with modernity
so my
you know there's a phrase in washington
dc you know what are the biggest
and most important factors in any
situation trying to analyze and
understand number one it's politics
number two it's politics and number
three it's politics
with china it's a bit like that what's
number one keep the country from falling
apart
number two keep the country from falling
number three etc
but but to to offer more specificity on
alternatives for two and three
you have a demographic change in that
society that's happening at the same
time as an economic one
meaning you are going to look at an
aging bulge of people we're going to
require more and more care from the
state
even though the economy is growing
at the same time costs
are
rising in the commercial sector for
labor you're seeing offshoring of
manufacturing from china to vietnam to
other countries that are more
politically palatable
and like europe that third point
on
balancing this notion of
how do you keep
a country
a population that large at work
fed
feeling like they're thriving invested
in a communist party system that has so
many contradictions
and and that's a very expensive
proposition too that if i were to try to
think through
what are the things that might undercut
china's military and strategic rise it's
dealing with that that last point
particularly
the trade
that's that's a very difficult one uh
it's it's difficult for me uh because i
keep seeing it through
the perspective of somebody like from
vladimir putin's point of view so so
that's how i'll answer it um
it's a great question uh i think it's a
lot harder absolutely
the idea that you know if you're a
professional expatriate you could just
be in any international capital i think
that's that's possible i mean in my
experience
it's funny i actually used to want to be
an ambassador to russia i was really
into skateboarding when i was you know
10 11 12 years old and at the same time
i was doing that
i was studying
russian with a tutor
at the university of washington seattle
i would literally get picked up driven
to
the
i would use the georgian phds
[Music]
i think it's really hard to understand a
culture profoundly
without having had experience in that
language i think it's it's really hard
i think as somebody who
tries to use fiction and
imagine
not just
other societies other cultures other
jobs other whatever
but also the future itself if you can
start by understanding what you don't
know
and this is a bit about like what i was
saying earlier
that helps you avoid some of that that
trap but but absolutely there's
a you know one of the experiences we had
uh it's not a secret but it's it's an
aspect of ghost fleet phantom i've never
been to hawaii and we wrote extensive
scenes in hawaii
so
spoiler
the story starts actually with an energy
discovery right with china having a
moment where literally there is a before
and after in realizing they can achieve
a form of energy independence
but the most the most chilling way the
book when you get past that starts is
the actual how does the third world war
begin right this question of does it
begin with uh
a missile that flies over the north pole
right is it a submarine lurking and
sinking an aircraft carrier
writing that book we thought a lot about
this question this is maybe the most
important question
well a false flag is part of how it
works
um
but we began
first with warren's space right
and looking at it from the position of
an american astronaut
on the international space station
and i'll um tipo de spoiler
who is locked out by these russian
cosmonauts because they're taking the
station over
and
quite quickly
the story moves to hawaii because
a little more spoiler
china seizes hawaii which is on one
level an outrageous
question to pose could this really
happen but they use a way of invading
with special forces not unlike how they
invaded afghanistan in 1979 so the
chinese use roll-on roll-off cargo ships
to pull up to the pier
first there are cheap chinese suvs that
are coming to the local market and the
next thing is a
tank and then an armored vehicle and
another tank
and that sort of deception
you know how do you hide in plain sight
anymore right this is something that
we're thinking about now with ukraine of
course how do you mobilize an invasion
force
that's capable of seizing territory from
the united states this is exercise
that's that's the old way right it's
effective right i mean the russians did
it i mean it's that's the narrative you
know
yeah
but the
exercise that
nato performs doesn't involve crossing
into
you know russia
uh just like russia crossed into ukraine
right
they also object objectives i think too
right uh and sometimes of course you
know you have the deterrence
the aspiration to deter by showing what
you're capable of
by engaging in the complex maneuver and
movement of tens of thousands of forces
nato's case different different nations
in our case we do a few nations
i don't know if military exercises
actually offer any deterrence
but that's another conversation
but but this notion though of
how do you
understand an environment without having
been there and
we had a review from one of the
newspapers in hawaii the honolulu star
advertiser
and my co-writer had been to hawaii a
little bit
but
they were really pleased with how well
we described hawaii
and you know from a practice perspective
seeing that it passed muster with them
that they received it well
it alleviated a lot of stress i had and
i kind of i thought
i never want to make that mistake again
of writing a book and not going to the
place and seeing the ground talking to
people
uh again and maybe that's the conceit of
a first novel is you know trying needing
to do that right we didn't really have
much choice
um but i feel like that was a really
really big moment of realizing that you
know creatively sometimes you take that
risk and it can pay off but it but it
also might not and that and that is back
to the idea of credibility you know
just like you're trying to understand
the language that a culture speaks you
know as a civilian writing about the
military there is a similar way of
speaking
that's vital to understand and it's not
just using acronyms
the shorthand you know if you sit in a
bar with people who are coming back from
deployment or going to deployment the
actual conversation they have is quite
acronym rich that to an outsider is
impenetrable and that's part of the
culture right having that that unique
language
but being able to essentially try to
better understand how to communicate
with
people in the military who are your
readers who are also needing to believe
the story you're creating
especially if it is
said in the future maybe they think it's
far-fetched or not possible if you're
really pushing the boundary a bit of of
what's possible
it's vital to be able to try to get into
that that kind of language and that's
not just about dialogue about having a
character say the right thing
it's also about
understanding what what and again in
that anthropological way what matters to
them how do they relate to their
families
how do they how do they deal with
outsiders uh those are all sort of the
crucial aspects i think of that you know
what you call world building
you know these aspects i think are
are
there's another way i think about this
too uh you know in this which is
it's not what
facts and details you have in a story
that are important it's what you leave
out right
really understanding just giving a
reader
enough that they can make part of the
movie in their own mind
but also allowing them
i would like to think to learn a little
bit too
because there's nothing worse
there's nothing worse than
reading something where you feel like
you're you're being lectured like too
right or you're losing the ability to
place yourself in that movie when i
write
i literally watch the movie you know and
this is just how my brain works every
writer is different
but especially in riding thrillers and
techno thrillers where it's very
visceral there's action
we're talking about
fighter jets and ghost fleet or
submarines and and
and everything um
it's really important for me to be able
to see the scene right and to kind of
move around it
in those different perspectives
and that allows you i think to really
understand
as if you're literally telling somebody
what's hey what happened right
from an analytical in kind of narrative
perspective to me that's one of the
easiest ways to get through writer block
writer's block is to answer that
question what's happening right now like
what just happened
it's a very fundamental point that
people often lose sight of when they get
kind of wrapped around their own ideas
[Music]
one of the ways i think about that is
what's it like to live in a world in
which all these technologies whether
it's robot police dogs whether it's
facial recognition software everywhere i
go how does that change you know how i
behave but
not just how i behave but how i think
you know the idea of self-censorship in
certain regimes is something that people
develop naturally you know can you enter
into an era of total surveillance where
everything from the watch you wear the
car you just got out of
the restaurant where you're eating it's
already there with your credit card and
your iphone to some extent
we're at a point where
that is going to
like that
and the question is
what next
fundamentally when i think about like
this ai and roboticized world is you
know what is the world that i want to
live in right and from to work backwards
from there and and that to me means if i
were to break this down a little bit
you know thinking about
the ability to not
feel
to feel in a human sense like you're
constantly surveilled that's an
extremely stressful and uncomfortable
and i think detrimental
experience to have
and we're already there and
there's a little bit like that uh you
know quote about being paranoid you know
which i'm going to probably not say
correctly um but the idea that you know
if it's not that you're
let's see it's not that they're not
watching you you're just not paranoid
enough or something like that
and
between our our iphones right and our
credit cards the amount of data that you
can use to model someone's behavior and
with ai you know twin them and create
essentially a fact totem of their life
of their existence
begins to fundamentally alter the
relationships that we have with one
another
and what's maybe most troubling about
that world is not realizing it
right it's people who essentially move
forward swiping on apps
tapping a phone to pay and don't
actually see all this happening because
of the vexing things about
many of the most effective technologies
like this is they're invisible right we
don't perceive them this is i think one
of the really interesting challenges
with ai because if someone is
to be upset or even enraged about
an ai-based decision making maybe it's
on their credit report
maybe they failed to get a loan
they don't know that that software was
based on data
that was never going to let them get a
loan in the first place because they
didn't have the right profile
and we don't have that understanding at
a civil society level of how any of this
stuff works so it's a question of both
education right
um
this summer is going to be a very very
charged one in the u.s because
the u.s supreme court is most likely to
essentially rewrite
allow states to rewrite abortion laws be
far more restrictive it's horrifying and
what that also to your point means that
we're going to have to think about this
question privacy in a very real way this
is not an abstract issue when someone
when somebody who has
an app that tracks their menstrual cycle
and suddenly
that is potentially data that state law
enforcement in a state that has a
restrictive abortion law
could use to prosecute them
maybe even if they're out of state
when they got an abortion to use their
location data or credit card receipts
and we don't have any
meaningful conversation about that and
you asked is it too late
right to be able to have that
conversation
there's a real risk of that
there are many
there is a chance that we will have to
have that debate quite soon
but
when you look at how laws are made in
the u.s when you look at the movements
that were required
at the political level
to change something as fundamental as
data rights
which is not a hot-button issue in
america nobody cares but it's vital
it's going to require
and maybe this is one aspect of what
happens
with the repeal of roe versus wade is
that it forces a very real and immediate
conversation that leads to some action
on data protection
but that's from a policy perspective
from a corporate perspective on the
other hand what is the moral and ethical
obligation of a technology company right
and and that is something that i don't
think we've had any debate on publicly
yet and we need to absolutely
causing harm i mean if you think about
the ability to cause harm with
you know electrons right you know
there's myriad ways to do that with
algorithms more specifically in social
media
how do we then advocate for ourselves as
individuals when
politicians may not care right i mean
this is a question of
not just advocacy but but determinism
and i i like to say i'm an optimist who
stares into the abyss
right
i i believe in human potential and
possibility
but i have a lot of sleepless nights
thinking about all the things that may
happen in the future in the near term
and and this is one of those periods
that's been really hard thinking about
that and trying to come up with
something that that doesn't take me out
of a very dark and very very depressing
uh
you know next next year or so with this
regard if if i want if i want to be
hopeful it's that
sometimes change comes from
an orthogonal and an alternative an
outside perspective
so perhaps
a debate
people in the streets over abortion
forces also to finally come to grips
with this question of data and privacy
because it has such
very real implications for the safety
and security of women in america
snowden i
i look at the snowden affair as
and again like it feels like one of the
most successful intelligence operations
potentially by russia that that we've
ever seen
um
looking at this
revelations that edward snowden was able
to produce by stealing data right in
files
and to have him end up in moscow
as a fugitive by way of hong kong
feels to me
and this is a
you know this is my my
my conspiratorial you know spy novelist
uh
mindset like like a like a like an
operation that you couldn't i couldn't
make that up and write it
uh that's my gut instinct in looking at
that
i have a lot of friends or programmers
yeah this is one of the big tensions
since snowden is what is the us what is
silicon valley and i mean silicon valley
in california but you know more broadly
what is their relationship with
nsa cia intelligence services government
in general because there is on one hand
a desire
to reject
a small number of people who are saying
we need to work on national security
problems but at a kind of keyboard level
there's still a lot of antagonism and i
expect that's that's a question of again
of trust
but when you ask about what do i think
about that snowden situation it's like
all the hair on the back of my neck just
goes up because it just that the inner
logic of it doesn't didn't make sense to
me and still doesn't
uh as being anything but an intelligence
operation and maybe i'm too
conspiratorial uh
you blow the whistle
like
like chelsea manning
like snowden
america is american
exclusively
no i think
this is one of the big conversations in
america about you know founding values
right now and i think the ideas of
freedom right
but how you
blow the whistle matters too
in the context
of
security
but if you leak documents
with the idea that you're advocating for
freedom and liberty
and
an expression of values that are to your
point or words constitutional
i don't know how you decide to go to a
place
where it's not safe to say what you want
where
a place like russia
maybe this question of physical security
i don't i don't i don't it doesn't seem
to be
juprine
the surveillance of at t and other data
centers in the u.s
american citizens yeah so using american
telco yeah yeah so i mean yeah so using
american telco nodes to capture domestic
data which is forbidden
it's forbidden yeah all right
[Music]
refugees
no
i don't i don't i think
the way that i would think thought about
that would be to go to some of the
lawmakers in congress potentially
a jane harmon somebody like that and
their committee and staff right who work
on the intelligence committee
and and
if you're willing to jeopardize
you know national secrets too sure right
because there's a cost in in
whistleblowing right i mean there's a
trade-off
but it doesn't it's still i can't get my
head around going to a country like
russia germany maybe
going to a member of congress and
working with the committee is a much
more to me the inner logic of it is more
coherent
the effect would still be the same
because even if you release the
information out there
but to find haven
in putin's russia just i can't i can't
get my head around it
right
i am very american
in front
i almost think you have to look at it in
two different pieces the private sector
and the governmental and figure out
where can you make quicker progress
i would like to think that
in parallel you can make the case for
on the commercial side
true ownership of your own data and then
it has actually economic value so that
10 years from now 15 years from now
when we have fewer hours available for
us to work
that whether it's selling our data or
our data is traded you know for
advertisers or whatever that there's
some economic value is that a solution
to basic income it's a little bit
dystopian but
so is that that that that you know trend
line
on the government side
the levels of
encryption that are available today and
that are coming
with quant
with with quantum computing
are fascinating in this regard because
there's two ways that can go and so when
i project on the government side of the
individual versus the state
there's both the ability to break open
any secret everywhere
i mean what an era that would be to see
be fascinating incredibly destabilized
[Music]
i don't know i don't know
i imagine the intelligence services of
every country are trying to break every
code everywhere
but i don't i really i mean i'm a you
know i don't know
but what on the quantum side again to
using my kind of like foresight brain
there is of course the idea that with
quantum computing
all the data that the chinese have
stolen can suddenly be unlocked that's
one that's one thing and that's a that's
a heck of a big threat uh because
suddenly with ai you can model a society
and manipulate it but
but but i'll but i'll just i'll just say
quickly
[Music]
oh i mean it's a bit like the thing that
makes you want to play music but
ultimately it's the intent of the
government right i absolutely matters
and similarly for me if if
if the french are stealing my data or
the chinese are on one level it doesn't
matter
right because you're losing ownership of
your information
but ultimately
i have less concern
about that former versus the latter
right
the national and the strategic objective
is different
the utilization and weaponization of
information particularly of the kind
that is stolen whether it's modeling
your
email for a future spearfishing attack
whether it is the ability to
duplicate or replicate your online
existence
during a war
i don't worry about france doing that to
me i worry about russia excuse me russia
yeah but also china right
so
the context is everything to me
and that's not to take anything away
from a clear-eyed
look at
history
but looking at where we are now and
what's happening in the future i can't i
can't see equivalency between the two
even when it comes to something as core
as is data
militarization
example imagine evoking
[Music]
hmm
so if i understand correctly it's the
idea i can speak slowly if you want well
if that's
right
i understand the idea that
all these tools
that the intelligence community in the
us particularly military for that matter
has assembled can just as easily be used
in the hands of an evil president
against its own citizens right just like
an authoritarian regime like china
absolutely something i would worry about
because
yeah absolutely because these are very
powerful tools and we've just come
through
an extremely disturbing presidency
with president trump
and he may run again he may win again
and what does that period of time look
like
so this question again about
being able to consider the role of the
individual in that society
that's being getting brought up with
data has comes to roe versus swade
earlier
has implications
right
in 2023 during the run-up to the
election 2024 during the election itself
i think every western citizen whether
it's in france whether it's in germany
for that matter whether it's in the us
needs to be constantly mindful of that
what we're using a technology for today
that may be done in the public interest
which is always a tension
certainly at the flip of a switch
can be wielded against you
and so that constitutional at that
foundational level
it's something that's not abstract
anymore
it's real
and
and trying to think about ways to get
people to care about that is important
because
it's there are a lot of complexities to
that question
[Music]
you know the answer i just gave is in
part part of it right you know the the
idea that we're living in societies
where
we know everything about us and yet
sometimes nothing right and feel like we
don't have a voice or agency
and imagine
uh in america
15 years from now
where
far fewer americans have jobs that they
find meaningful
that there is more
resistance and organizing on the far
right by politicians but also by other
people who are
very interested in almost in an anarchic
sense creating chaos
and i'm not even pinning anything on the
russians there's no russians in this
book
this is a domestic issue
and and so
the idea
that you can find yourself in a world in
which
everything that you felt worked great
suddenly doesn't because there's been a
paradigm shift economically politically
culturally that's what motivated us to
write this book control
we are moving headlong into an era in
which ai and robotics are going to
transform every aspect of society
it's going to transform
the fundamental things that give us our
identity what what jobs we
do it's going to change everything from
how politicians in a sense are able to
message us but also control their
populations
with these very same technologies
and nobody wants to talk about this
this is not a popular discussion this is
like a really depressive
uh
line of thinking you know i'll often
like finish a coffee with someone we
both kind of look at each other we're
just like god
but that's why we write
right we're trying to allow people to
understand the things we want to avoid
that was true with flood phantom it's
true with control
we need to understand and think the
unthinkable
what
we might be missing about the world now
because it's uncomfortable we don't want
to think about it and to me a novel is a
perfect way to do that
you can still be entertained and kind of
have that heightened awareness and i
think that's crucial to be able to do
that in a manner that's accessible to
anybody anybody can read a book you
don't even have to buy it
go to the library
my hope is by understanding these very
complex questions about technology from
a human perspective from you know this
this fbi agent and not just her but her
family i mean this is a novel that's
about a fbi agent hunting her terrorist
nemesis
her robot partner
but
but also
her relationship with her husband
and her daughter and her husband was a
lawyer who went to american ivy league
universities the grand nicole
never did anything wrong in his life
a good guy
somebody who in america believes the
system
owes them something
and because of an algorithm at his law
firm
his very high paying job
was taken away
and that has profound implications for
our hero right because she's not only
become
the sole breadwinner the sole income in
their household
but also the very nature of what she has
to do to save washington
involves working with a robot that her
husband despises she hates he hates the
fact that she's working with the very
technology that's made him miserable
that's ruining
society and that contradiction to me is
fascinating
and this is a really human experience
right it's a very different kind of
story than leflot phantom
for this reason it's very much about
getting inside the heads of people who
live in this future america
machine learning
[Music]
american way of life
inequality is
a structural problem in america that may
could ruin the country in the next 20 to
30 years
our inability to educate our young
to take care of our sick
and i and i sound
uh you know pessimistic here but we have
very little meaningful progress
to tackle these problems in a meaningful
way
and that's not even to speak of gun
violence
but just simply looking at education and
health care
you know creating economic opportunity
in a world if america we talked earlier
about these kind of three paradigms
right if you want to be the place where
you want the smartest people to come
it would be
sensible to try to be the place where
you have some of the most best educated
and smartest in a in a broad sense
in the world
you can't outsource innovation
right
and there is very little interest
politically in doing that
it's extremely disheartening as someone
who has children and looks at the future
i'm constantly weighing this question of
is the world going to be worse
is there a chance it can be better and
again that's not even considering
climate
uh in global warming
and so
part of writing a story and spending you
know two years thinking these dystopian
thoughts
living inside in my head that apartment
that laura keegan lives in
is about coming to grips with this
paradigm
of how we're
just simply
not rising to the occasion when we know
what we need to do and nobody wants to
to allow great economic inequality in
america and i'm not a socialist at all
i'm a capitalist for sure
uh but to allow such
yawning inequality
uh i'm not a socialist socialist
capitalist you know
right
the ability
to allow such extreme wealth
and this is again a theme in the book
to
allow an executive who runs a
multi-billion dollar corporation to make
hundreds of times the amount of their
employee that doesn't make any sense and
i spend a lot of my career as a
financial journalist
right interviewing executives
interviewing employees covering the
biggest bankruptcies some of them in
america
seeing the rise of the first internet
economy and its crash
seeing the airline industry crash after
9 11
seeing the second.com crash i've covered
all this stuff the bankruptcies the auto
industries i've seen the economic
carnage that can happen
and and we're still unable to understand
how to make our society more resilient
right
and as someone who specializes in
defense who works in and around these
issues very seriously with intent
i still think we don't pay enough
attention
to these softer issues
it's so important to consider national
dynamism not just in terms of an order
of battle
the strength of the military but how are
we going to
take care of some of the weakest or
those who can't help themselves
there's no future without that
and that again may be pessimistic and
and i and i again i'm a proud american
but i'm incredibly disheartened
by the situation we find ourselves in
france
um
this is this aspect of education right
are we at a point where people don't
understand what's happening what's being
done to them right
uh i think
it is extremely is getting easier and
easier for political leaders to take
advantage of people's inattention and
lack of critical thinking
right
it's not a question of innate
intelligence like like idiocracy
literally supposes a decline in iq
but we are seeing a weaponization of
inattention which which is bizarre to
say
but it is incredibly
destructive
if
people are not able to think critically
about everything from
whether a new policy is being introduced
to take advantage of them but they're
being told it's for their benefit
repealing obamacare are one of our most
successful health care benefits in the
country that was offered
in an unprecedented way to more
americans than had ever been done before
and and it was attacked as if it was
one of the most destructive things that
could have been done to the country
nothing could be further from the truth
one of the really interesting
experiences during covid and it relates
to the theme in control because we talk
about basic income
the idea that in a world of less work
what are we going to do for paying for
our basic needs if not a quality of life
that's meaningful
during the pandemic in the united states
i think like in france there was
incredible government support in terms
of cash people literally got cash
deposited into their bank accounts
which was in effect a prototype of what
our future may hold
but the conversation about that wasn't
one that was forward-looking it was very
much locked in the politics of the
moment
and whether there's a viable way to do
basic income we have to figure that out
if that's possible
but the point is the inability to think
critically and observe what's happening
whether that's a fair trade-off or not
right is it worth the debt issuance is
it worth the inflationary risk all the
traditional political and policy
factors
it's very hard to have those
conversations at a national level look
at how cable news is done in the u.s
it's about emotional response more than
analytical
development
i struggle to watch
i don't i try not to i spent again my
whole journalistic career with the tv on
next to me for 10 to 12 hours a day
i've had my fill but the point is we're
at a point where it's not useful for
thinking even social media i have a
love-hate relationship with twitter
which is a marvelous way to connect with
people
to know things that might not have
otherwise come across my transom but too
many times the algorithm narrows my
world view rather than opens it
too many times my ability to concentrate
and to think the kind of thoughts that i
want to put into a book that feel truly
novel that feel new
that again everyone's looking here i
want to look there
social media destroys that
i'm so conflicted about that and the
future that we talk about and controls
ultimately an expression of that that
inner feeling
of really trying to understand that for
every technological potential benefit
there's a cost
one of the things that we hope is that
people in the
in silicon valley and the technology
community can use the book
to better understand the consequences
of these kinds of
inventions that have immense market
value make people rich with stock
options or
whatever
but maybe the wrong thing to do for
america
[Music]
well
i am getting more this is an area where
i am getting more hopeful
because we're having in the u.s at least
a more sophisticated conversation about
how to develop curate
and advance good ideas most people who
work staff jobs
in the us military live and
live by powerpoint
right it is a very
very ineffective way of communicating
ideas
there's some you know you can find
online examples of some of the most
complex and nonsensical charts that are
out there
which in effect serve nobody and how
many hours could be saved and better
spent training how much money
could be conserved
if
you essentially banned powerpoint as a
way to run a modern military like the us
a day without powerpoint would be
actually a fascinating creative prompt
but it speaks to
not the problem of not having creativity
in the ranks because there are
literally limitless amounts of smart
people who are trying to do the job
one of the biggest concerns right now
with ai and robotics is what's called
innovation theater
the idea that you can throw 10 million
dollars 20 million dollars at a an idea
or a concept small company
and
tick a box you can make a powerpoint
presentation that says hey we're
investing in ai
even if there's no intention ever to
deploy it at scale
especially across a force as large as
ours
that is a profound risk
that if you
perform this kind of theater without
actual intent of transformation
and transforming big organizations is so
hard
people who
invest their careers in
forming parts of innovation cells
for the most part
tend to have shorter careers
people who want to have long careers
don't get as many
opportunities to step outside a fairly
prescribed
path
yeah
my hope though and this is something
that you've seen again this is where i
have that
look i mean i like i say i'm i like to
be optimistic but i have a lot of a lot
of pessimism in me and
this yet is one area because i'm seeing
more and more senior officers
people who are on their way to become
generals even some of the recent
generals we had
who
have been able
to advocate
for this kind of working and protect
people in their careers to let them keep
advancing right because it's not often
even what you're doing in your given job
if you're the senior most senior leader
it's figuring out how to protect the
people who have other good ideas who can
be part of your legacy
one of the really big tests right now in
the u.s is the reform of the united
states marine corps
the united states marine corps is
abandoning its commitment to tanks the
m1 tank
the ethnosync
this is heretical this is a profoundly
destabilizing
set of policies and it's the most
correct thing i've seen in a long time
and that's a process that took time
from the prior commandant
commandant burger and now excuse me uh
neller and now burger
it's posing
incredible risks politically for the
marine corps
because the forces within
the retired marine corps community are
advocating against it saying you're
defanging you're taking the the claws
away so to speak
uh you're making the marine corps
subordinate to the navy even more so
than it already might be
it's going to make them
unable to fight china
and yet to me it's one of the most
successful
bureaucratic transformations
with
the roots of a good idea
to fundamentally re-envision everything
from the kind of rifle a marine corps
carries
to
the way that
small groups of soldiers on land
that are from conventional forces not
forces special forces
can have a strategic impact right
that has not been part of the
traditional conversation
about what to do with land forces in the
u.s military but now we're having that
and that's where part of that optimism
comes from
because
the staff work to affect those changes
the buy-in the convincing the
the
the tribal dialogue that needs to occur
within those different communities
because people are giving away things
that they hold dear especially aviation
that's really hard to do
but in this notion of transformation
this notion of
breaking bureaucracy
to do the right thing
this is something really to watch
if it fails
if it's repealed that's going to be
extremely troubling
and bodes very poorly for future
transformations that are going to come
and be required from the adoption of
everything from robotic aircraft to the
next generation of unmanned tanks
one one of the one of the biggest
one one of the the biggest uh
technological
trends that we're going to see is
miniaturization with robotics and of
course the increasing use of software
in warfare and what i think is really
vexing very difficult for the us
is that in our defense industrial
relationship software does not have a
zip code meaning there is not a
congressman or a lawmaker who can own a
program in the same way
if you build
a fighter plane
in my district
i'm an advocate for sustaining that
program
if you build a targeting algorithm or a
flight algorithm
in pittsburgh that doesn't become part
of the political establishment and is
much harder to defend and see through
that's the system we have so i'm very
mindful of that of that transformation
similarly
with the idea that robotics is going to
allow more and more miniaturization
we're no longer going to be buying 200
million dollar fighter jets
we're going to be buying one million
dollar aircraft that has profound
economic implications for
big publicly traded companies that don't
want that that are not equipped for that
world and even our our smallest
innovative companies of which there are
growing number that want to work with
the defense department it's hard for
them
to be able to get the chance to
participate because everything is so
locked up
is
[Music]
i think about uh
this this question of of needing to be
able to think without thinking is really
vital for analysis to find ways to
process
what you've been taking in
in a it's not a passive way but like the
way i act
the way i access this
is finding physical activity where i
can't think about i ride a i'm a big
cyclist so i'll ride a mountain bike
you're on a mountain bike you can't
think about defense policy you're trying
not to hit a tree you're trying to you
know avoid whatever a log
but almost every single time that i
actually make time for a ride
i have ideas that i didn't have before
and because like i was saying with
social media we're bombarded by in my
brain i'm constantly looking i'm looking
at the sticker on your computer and
thinking is that something inspirational
right i'm constantly sensing and seeing
i look at a cereal box and i'm and i'm
reading it right that's just how my
brain works so i'm constantly taking
things in and so i have to find time to
process it
and you know i'm not a writer who can
sit at a desk for eight hours a day i
can write 90 minutes at a time very
intently
you know if i write in a cafe people
look at me funny because i'm
on the keyboard
and and that to me is part of
understanding how to get it good ideas
like where does a good idea come from
you know
and and that's how i've come to
understand it's taken a long time to
appreciate that because as a journalist
you're locked into a chair you're locked
into a news cycle you have a deadline
whether it's a a newspaper printing
whether it's in a financial newswire
which is real time
i've now allowed myself to work in a way
though where the deadlines are longer
and that it's given me more time to
think and that was one of the best
decisions i think i made to create that
space
because it also allows more
introspection about what am i missing
right
and and working with a partner like like
peter singer
is also a helpful check on
that notion of
where are my biases right what am i
missing and having someone who's smarter
than you who you work with is one of the
most important qualities in a teammate
being able to have an honest
conversation a trusting one where you
know and we are lucky we have a
friendship as much as an intellectual
relationship too which is not always the
case in team writing right often
folks don't have that
but there's a fundamental level of trust
that's reflected in how we write too you
know when you read uh la fleur phantom
when you read control you can't tell who
wrote which sections
because when we write we give the other
person our section might be a whole
chapter it might be a page
and the other person has full license to
destroy it
completely
and that's a big leap a lot of writers
simply cannot do that there's too much
ego right there's too much investment in
the words
i think one of the things having been a
journalist
having been somebody who's writing was
constantly savaged
and destroyed by my editors to make it
better
allowed me to understand almost a notion
of trust the process right
uh to know that like i actually may not
have the best idea the best way to
express something
and i think that's one of the reasons
why our creative partnership works so
well and why the books come across
whether why they why they work
[Music]
um
if we can talk about anything
i think i would probably
try to understand
the larger
forces and themes that are at work
in civil society
and what are the levers
that we as individuals or together
we can pull to change them what is the
notion of like public will right and
this this is a question of
not just like pure descent but but
the way that technology allows us to
communicate with one another
is incredibly interesting for its
opportunities right it allows us to
network to flash mob to whatever
but there's a darker side to that too
that i think about a lot
that that can be weaponized and this
idea of
whether we have a airland air domain a
land domain a space domain a c domain
is it time for
cyber of course
is it time for a sixth domain a
conversation about this notion of a
human domain a cognitive domain
this is a one of my favorite things to
think about and
it is
tied very much to the question of
technological advance
political decline
and the changing nature of warfare
itself
that to be able to
succeed militarily or strategically
without
ever deploying a soldier
is a really fascinating aspect
of conflict in the 21st century
exactly
um
[Music]
william gibson who's a science fiction
writer right who very much is somebody
who uh
birthed the rise of what we used to call
the cyberpunk movement and has moved on
to other other kind of concepts in his
writing
uh and i would i would consider him a
philosopher even if he is you know in
not a national academy sense
he is someone who had a very gritty and
realistic way of writing
that helped me when i was very young
when i read it understand
this aspect to technology
that maybe it's not everything it's
supposed to be
right
uh it's a bit like in the 1980s when i
grew up when you saw depictions of the
future everything was clean
right you'd have a lot of white
computers white furniture nothing was
ever dirty in a william gibson novel
everything is dirty and gritty and
grotty
i think that's that's that's really
really really a vital aspect of how i
kind of think about the future
uh in terms of
uh a pure political philosopher
i'm trying to better understand uh the
laws of armed conflict you know from an
ethical framework in reading
historical and traditional texts
um
thomas aquinas things like that and i do
that with the laypersons with a novice
perspective having not studied that
extensively
but in thinking about future conflict
it's incredibly important i think to
look foundationally what we establish
the laws of armed conflict with
for a final perspective
on a philosophical source of inspiration
i'm trying to think about another writer
and probably
again
talk about cognitive warfare
she may be the five star general of the
future war
framework
right
ray bradbury is an american science
fiction writer who again like william
gibson almost takes a philosophical
approach
to thinking about not just the future
because not all of his stories dealt
with that he dealt with the strange the
abstract sometimes
but but fundamentally never losing sight
of the human experience
in
alternate realities that we may or may
not
have
but that fundamentally reflect the world
we're in right so fahrenheit 451 is a
novel was i recently watched an american
version of that on film
uh with michael b jordan which is really
good
but so i went back and reread the novel
and and fundamentally what was
interesting about that book
was
montag the fireman the man whose career
is to burn books of course he's been
hiding them
but his relationships with his wife
is very disturbing
but very relevant for understanding the
world
secondly his emerging mentor who's one
of the dissidents
of the
librarians of sorts right who's really
working to preserve the written word
in the last moments of sort of this
aspect of humanity
and that's a very powerful meditation on
what it means to share knowledge to be
human together because the world that
montag lives in is dehumanized
completely
it's nothing more than neurological
inputs from screens right the notion of
reflection that the book offers that ray
bradbury poses to the reader to
understand is one of the
cornerstones of of of of community right
not even just civilization but community
books are how we understand each other
that speaks to me i don't think i
thought about this as profoundly when i
was young i just liked reading dandelion
wine or martian chronicles or whatever
but as i spend more time writing it's
incredibly important
particularly that story
is
yeah my wife uh jokes that peter is my
work wife meaning you know we we spend
so much time emotionally it's a good
tree and and mentally together because
even though we live in different cities
we're never far from each other it's
quite funny um
but i think actually
both of us have come to know each other
better through the work and actually
during covet it was really interesting
we both came to i think rely on each
other as friends more and more than we
had even having worked on two novels
and and that's that's a remarkable thing
i mean it's a profound thing it's a
personal thing
but i believe is really really
wonderful right to have that level of
friendship intellectually our brains are
certainly different i have a very short
i'm coming to understand my mind better
the more i work and my attention span is
short
so we'll be having a conversation
especially if it's a planning
conversation and i want to skip to the
most interesting thing right i want to
get right into it and it's like nope we
at process here and and that is one of
my big blind spots is process right i'm
very instinctive
i see something
it intrigues me i want to find it pick
at it understand it
integrate it with something else
i've had to come to learn how that is a
liability right especially in big
projects that take years you can't do
those things impulsively or
instinctively
there's a there's a logistics process to
them
and that's something because my
co-writer peter has had more experience
writing non-fiction books he's written a
phd
uh has a wonderful process and there's
another
aspect of his personality that's just
wonderful and is one of my other blind
spots i'm not very good at
advocacy or promotion right i mean i
love talking and having conversations i
could do this you know all night long
but but when it comes to really
understanding what it means to be a
writer
you have to be very savvy
about how you understand the marketplace
understand how you fit into it
and that has been so helpful and it's
one of his strongest
things that he brings to this
relationship
because i'm just not as good at that i'm
getting better but i work i have to work
on that actively
intellectually
she
[Music]
i don't have a lot of friends
[Laughter]
i
having having worked in washington dc
where everyone is extremely in the kind
of policy world well-educated very
engaged
uh
i now live out i live in boston in a in
a community that's not part of the
policy world
and i actually have come to really like
that because i may tell someone
about what i do and they look at me like
what like that's a job right
and what that forces you to do and i
don't mean that in a in a denigrating
way
it's rather a reflection of how the
wider world understands the things that
many of us spend our lives trying to get
better at
and that forces a lot of reflection
right so i don't actually
get that innate you know antipathy when
someone doesn't care about you know
china and their threat of a war in the
next five years
uh instead
i almost try to understand it more from
what's important to them because
that's mostly maybe a writer's trick
but fundamentally when you're trying to
understand what's happening in the
future
you know i'm not writing books about me
like i don't want to i don't want to
write a book about me right i'm trying
to write a book about real people
and not everybody is you know going to
be obsessed with things i'm obsessed
with and so being able to be
open at a human level i think that's
part of my optimism too right it's just
trying to meet people where they are
if you've driven in boston
it's easy to hate humanity
maybe paris too
uh and to think that we're hopeless uh
but in seriousness to spend
time with people to really see them
where they are
is i think one of the best things you
can actually do
is
i would
say if you want to read a book about
america
that is i think one of the most
interesting it's actually a trilogy
by don winslow
which is
starts i'm blanking on the name it just
finished with the final book called the
border
it's about essentially the rise of the
narco economy
in mexico in the u.s
and following it through a very
specific and unique character who is
essentially a dea agent
uh it is one of the most important
pieces of american fiction
against three novels maybe 1200 pages or
more altogether
most recently the border
the power of the dog is the first one
the car the cartel is the second one
and the third is the border it deals
with everything from
the drug industry
to political corruption in the white
house
it is a true saga okay
no no it does it does it deals
it it looks at at not just that but
everything from private military
contractors doing counter it's it's a
complete story and his ability to
research and i think he's written at
this point 15 or 16 novels so he's a
master
so so i would read the power of the dog
cartel i would read
the border
i would go back to william gibson who i
mentioned earlier
i would recommend everybody read his
older books but he has a more recent
novel
called the peripheral
which is set in america again it
describes a future very dystopian
america in which there's more automation
sure
but it deals with a really interesting
set of problems that in part come from
the invention of
what is called quantum tunneling the
ability to communicate between different
realities and that sounds like science
fiction
but it's more than that and it's very
much a story about the future of america
particularly politics and power which i
highly recommend
and he has a sequel to that as well
called agency
the third book i might say
that was influential for me
from
i mean i read all the time but when i
was very young
and i'll go back to what we talked about
earlier with the one of the first the
second tom clancy book red storm rising
it's not high literature but i read that
book at 12 years old
and what's interesting is so did my
co-writer peter singer we both had the
same experience really for the first
time picking a book up and not moving
until you finished it right and that was
the kind of kid i was like i would do
that
and when we wrote la fleur fantome
going back to rereading that book for
inspiration which we very much did
was a really kind of alpha omega moment
of going back to you know i sometimes
joke that what i do now is not much
different than what i thought i should
be doing at 15 or 16 years old right you
know reading and writing you know
fiction and and
and things like that
but those those books are all quite
different
but for each
don winslow is the kind of writer i
aspire to be same with william gibson
who i think can really tackle these
these complex subjects beautifully
and then you know clancy for just being
the first seed that was planted
why is america the most beautiful
country
is not anymore why is it not
oh um
i think like i was saying our inability
to take care of one another i mean if i
could reduce it to a human level no
policy no politics
we stop taking care of one another
that's not religion that's not that's
not doctrine that's just at a human
level
that's been our divisions are being
exploited every single day for economic
gain for political gain and it's hurt
our ability to take care of each other
that sounds almost like a christian
episcopalian message but but we we need
to do that better and if and if you were
to think about resiliency
if you were to think about our future as
a place where people want to live and
have children
hmm
i wish i had some really uh
concise aphorism
i think about this a lot with my my my
daughters
i think i would go back to what i just
said take care of other people
when you're ever faced with a hard
decision are you taking care of somebody
else
i
when you think about the decisions we
make in our lives we have to live with
them they come to us in the night they
invade our minds during the day
it's important to be able to make
decisions even when we have to make bad
ones because sometimes we do we have to
live with them
and i think if you can revert to a
principle like that
and again i know this sounds uh corny as
you'd say in english but but i think
it's a fundamental human quality
that
that that we can't be afraid of
especially when so many again so many
people are trying to pull us apart or
get us to fight one another i think i
would put in that bottle
take care of other people
if i if i think about how i raise my
daughters i want them to be adventurous
take risks physically emotionally
intellectually but to know how to take
care of other people and that's hard to
teach it's not easy it's definitely not
easy
august cool merci
[Applause]
merced
[Music]
you